الان لا تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بوقوع سلسله
انفجارات قويه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
بتزامن مع رصد اجسام طائره في سماء
المدينه وقد تصدى الدفاعات الجويه لها
قالت الاداره العسكريه في كييف ان القوات
الروسيه شنت هجوما معقدا والثامن هذا
الشهر من اتجاهات المختلفه في وقت واحد
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه باستخدام الطائرات
بدون طيار وصواريخ كروز وربما الصواريخ
الباليستيه واصفه الهجمه بالاستثنائيه في
كثافتها مؤكده انها اقصى عدد صواريخ
الهجوميه في اقصر فتره زمنيه واكد القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه ان 18
صاروخا اطلقت نحو كيافا في الهجوم فجر
اليوم وقد تم اسقاطها جميعا
مراسله جزيره حسان مسعود حسان اهلا بك
نبدا بهذا التصريح الى القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وحديثه عن 18
صاروخ اطلقت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه في
الهجوم فجر اليوم وقد تم كما يقول اسقاطها
ماذا في التفاصيل
نعم سفيان هو التصريح الابرز الذي يوضح ما
حدث خلال هذه الليله الطويله والصعبه على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
ويحتوي على معلومات مهمه
تعبر عن هذا الهجوم الذي وصف بالهجوم
الاعقد على العاصمه الاوكرانيه على
اوكرانيا يتحدث القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه
عن ان هذه الهجمه الصاروخيه تمت عبر
ثمانيه عشر صاروخا هذه الصواريخ من بينها
سته صواريخ من طراز كنجال اطلقت من سته
طائرات
قاذفات استراتيجيه روسيه من طراز ميج 31
كا وايضا تسع صواريخ من طراز كاليبر اطلقت
من السفن من البحر الاسود بالاضافه الى
صواريخ من طراز اس 4 واسكندر امن وهذه
ايضا الصواريخ هي صواريخ كروز
وبعيده المدى وكذلك باليستيه هذه الصواريخ
18 اطلقت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف
ويقول قائد القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
كما ايضا القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انهم
تمكنوا من اسقاط كافه هذه الصواريخ في
سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كما ايضا في
المنطقه الجنوبيه وهي تتجه باتجاه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه وهذا ربما ما يعبر عن حجم
الانفجارات القويه جدا التي سمعناها خلال
هذه الليله تمام الساعه الثالثه ونصف من
فجر هذا اليوم عندما اطلقت
رشقات مكثفه من الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه في محاوله لاعتراض هذه
الصواريخ ولكن من بين التفاصيل المهمه
والتي من المهم ان نشير اليها نحن الان
هنا في حي ابولون احد الاحياء التي قالت
السلطات ان حطام للصواريخ سقطت في هذا
المكان
وتبين ان السلطات قد رفعت بقايا هذه
الصواريخ وازالتها من هذه المنطقه حيث
نتواجد ولكن هناك منطقه اخرى وهي منطقه
سليمانسكي وهذه المنطقه كان عمده كييف قد
اكد ان مبنى غير سكني كما وصفه تعرض
لحريق كبير خلال الليله الماضيه احترقت
هناك ايضا عدد كبير من السيارات
والدفاعات او الدفاع المدني كان يعمل هناك
وفرق الانقاذ كانت تعمل هناك حاولنا بكل
الطرق ان نصل الى ذاك المكان ولكن ابلغنا
بشكل واضح انه من غير الممكن وغير المسموح
ان نتوجه الى تلك المنطقه وهذا ربما يشير
الى ان المنطقه هناك هي منطقه بالغه
الحساسيه بالنسبه للسلطات وهو ما يمنع ان
ان نصل اليها هناك وهناك كان الحدث الاكبر
على ما يبدو وفق البيانات الرسميه ورفقه
ما اعلن عنه عمده كييف كذلك الطرقات
باتجاه منطقه سلم مقطوعه بالكامل هناك
وتلك المنطقه منطقه هي قريبه من حيث نسكن
ومن حيث رصدنا الدفاعات الجويه
وايضا وهج الانفجارات القويه التي
سامعيناها هناك هل هذا يعني ان الصواريخ
تمكنت من الوصول الى تلك المنطقه ام ان
حطام الصواريخ كما تقول السلطات هو الذي
سقط في تلك المنطقه واثر على ما يبدو على
منشاه استراتيجيه وللبنيه التحتيه كما
تصفها السلطات وادى الى هذا الحريق الكبير
والى هذا الحدث
الحساس بالنسبه لسلطات الاوكرانيه نتركه
للساعات القادمه لنطلع على مزيد من
التفاصيل حسام مسعود شكرا جزيلا لك